Trois types de dispositifs mentaux sont actuellement utilisés.
Du pétrole comme celui que vous avez vu ici
C'en est un autre avec les 220 amortisseurs.
Il y a un dispositif mental semblable à un mur, mais c'est
120 avions disposent également de cet amortisseur de frein.
C'est comme être appelé
Il existe au total 404 types de dispositifs mentaux. Ces trois types
j'utilise
[musique]
Un amortisseur d'huile est placé ici.
Par contre il y a de l'huile dans le cylindre.
C'est là-dedans, donc la vraie chose est plus grande.
C'est si gros qu'une personne ne peut pas le tenir
Il y en a, mais c'était pendant ce tremblement de terre.
Ça pousse comme ça
Que se passe-t-il là-bas qui ne cesse de rétrécir ?
Je suppose que cela finira par arriver.
Il fait de plus en plus chaud, ce qui veut dire
La tige de vibration convertit l'énergie de la vibration en chaleur.
le convertir en énergie de
En conséquence, les secousses du bâtiment sont supprimées.
et
[musique]
Voici des produits sanitaires pour femmes.
Katuna
Craquelins en conserve et feuille de sauvetage
Couverture en aluminium
[musique]
C'est une maison assez vieille.
La situation est que le bâtiment ne sera ni modernisé ni reconstruit.
Environ 60 % de la superficie du quartier est désormais constituée de maisons en bois.
La situation actuelle est devenue ce qu’on appelle une zone concentrée.
Alors parlons d’abord de ces choses.
Nous prenons actuellement des mesures pour améliorer
C’est là que nous concentrons nos efforts.
[musique]
Masu
Celui-ci est actuellement en cours de reconstruction.
n'est-ce pas
[musique]